Fui operada del cerebro hace 18 años,
y, desde ese día, la ciencia del cerebro
se me ha convertido en una pasión personal.
Soy ingeniera
y quiero decirles que
recientemente me he unido al grupo Moonshot. de Google,
donde he tenido una divisón a mi cargo;
la divisón de visualización de Google X.
Pero todo el trabajo del que hablaré hoy aquí
sobre la ciencia del cerebro,
lo realicé antes de unirme a Google
o fuera de mi trabajo allí.
Habiendo dicho esto, existe un estigma
cuando te sometes a una operación de cerebro.
¿Sigues siendo igual de inteligente o no?
De no ser así, ¿podrás volver a ser inteligente?
Luego de la neurocirugía,
me faltaba una parte del cerebro,
y tenía que vivir con ello.
No era la materia gris, pero era la parte pegajosa muerta del centro
que crea importantes hormonas y neurotransmisores.
Inmediatamente luego de la operación,
tuve que decidir qué cantidad tomar,
de más de una docena de potentes químicos cada día,
ya que si no tomaba nada,
moriría en pocas horas.
Cada día, durante los últimos 18 años,
he tenido que decidir sobre las combinaciones
y mezclas de químicos,
y tratar de conseguirlas, para seguir con vida.
Más de una vez me he salvado por poco.
Pero, por suerte, tengo alma de experimentalista,
por lo que decidí que experimentaría
para tratar de obtener las dosis óptimas
ya que realmente no existe un mapa claro
que lo diga en deatalle.
Comencé a probar con mezclas diferentes,
y quedé sorprendida al ver cómo
pequeños cambios en las dosis
cambiaban drásticamente mi autoimagen,
mi sentido de quién era yo, mi forma de pensar,
mi comportamiento con los demás.
Un caso particularmente impresionante:
durante unos meses, probé dosis
y químicos típicos para un hombre de veinte,
y me sorprendí al ver cómo cambiaban mis pensamientos.
(Risas)
Estaba siempre furiosa,
pensaba todo el tiempo en el sexo,
y me creía que era la persona más inteligente
de todo el mundo, y...
(Risas)
...por supuesto, muchas veces en el pasado he conocido varios tipos así,
o quizás algunas versiones atenuadas.
Resulté como un extremo.
Pero mi gran sorpresa fue
que no estaba intentando ser arrogante.
De hecho, estaba intentando,
un tanto insegura,
arreglar un problema que tenía al frente,
y simplemente no sucedía así.
Así, no podía manejarlo.
Cambié mis dosis.
Pero, pienso que esa experiencia me dió
una nueva apreciación sobre los hombres
y sobre lo que tienen que atravesar.
Desde entonces
me llevo mejor con los hombres.
Lo que trataba de lograr.
al ajustar esas hormonas
y neurotransmisores y demás,
era recuperar mi inteligencia
luego de la enfermedad y la operación;
mi pensamiento creativo, mi flujo de ideas.
Suelo pensar casi siempre en imágenes,
y eso se convirtió en mi punto de referencia clave:
¿cómo consigo esas imágenes mentales
que utilizo para crear prototiposrápidos,
mis ideas, si se quiere?
Probando nuevas ideas y
recreando situaciones.
Esta clase de pensamientos no es nueva.
Filósofos como Hume, Descartes y Hobbes
veían las cosas de forma similar.
Pensaban que las imágenes y las ideas mentales
eran la misma cosa.
Hoy hay quienes cuestionan esta idea,
y existen muchas discusiones sobre cómo funciona la mente.
Para mí es simple:
para la mayoría de nosotros, las imágenes mentales
son fundamentales para el pensamiento creartivo e inventivo.
Por lo que, luego de varios años,
logre encontrar el punto justo y tengo ya montones de
grandiosas mágenes mentales, realmente vívidas, bien sofisticadas
y bien estructuradas.
Ahora, estoy trabajando en
cómo llevar bien rápido estas imágenes mentales,
de mi mente a la pantalla de la computadora.
¿Se imaginan qué sucedería
si un director de cine fuese capaz de usar
su imaginación únicamente para dirigir al mundo que tiene al frente?
¿O si un músico pudiese extraer la música de su cabeza?
Hay increíbles posibilidades con esto,
como la forma con que la gente creativa
puede llegar a compartir a la velocidad de la luz.
Y la verdad es que, la única dificultad
para lograr hacer esto
es simplemente aumentar la resolución de nuestros sistemas de escaneo cerebral.
Déjenme mostrarles por qué creo que estamos bastante cerca de llegar a esto
con dos experimentos recientes
realizados por dos grupos destacados en neurociencia.
Ambos utilizaron tecnología IRM,
imagen por resonancia magnética funcional,
para representar el cerebro.
Aquí pueden ver el escaneo cerebral realizado por
Giorgio Ganis y sus colegas de Harvard.
La columna de la izquierda muestra el escaneo del cerebro
de una persona que mira una imagen.
La columna del medio muestra el escaneo del cerebro
de ese mismo individuo
mientras se imaginaba, viendo esa misma imagen.
La columna de la derecha se creó
restando el contenido de la columna central de la de la izquierda.
Se ve que la diferencia es casi nula.
Esto se repitió en muchos individuos diferentes
con muchas imágenes diferentes,
siempre con un resultado similar.
La diferencia entre ver una imagen
e imaginar ver esa misma imagen
es casi nula.
Ahora, permítanme compartirles otro experimento.
Este es del laboratorio de Jack Gallant en Berkeley, California.
Ellos lograron convertir las ondas cerebrales
en campos visuales reconocibles.
Pongámoslo de esta manera.
En este experimento, se mostró a las personas
cientos de horas de videos de YouTube
mientras se escaneaban sus cerebros
para crear un gran acervo de reacciones del cerebro
ante las secuencias de video.
Luego, se les mostró una película con imágenes nuevas,
gente nueva, nuevos animales,
y mientras tanto se registraba un nuevo escaneo.
La computadora, utilizando solo la información cerebral del escaneo
lo decodificó
para mostrar lo que parecía que la persona estaba viendo.
A la derecha se pueden ver las deducciones de la computadora,
y a la izquierda, el video que se les mostró.
Esto nos dejó boquiabiertos.
Estamos bien cerca de lograrlo.
Solo necesitamos mejorar la resolución.
Y ahora, recuerden que cuando uno ve una imagen
y cuando se imaginan esa misma imagen,
se crea en el cerebro el mismo mapeo.
Esto se llevó a cabo con los sistemas de escaneo cerebral
de mayor resolución disponibles hoy,
y su resolución se incrementó
como mil veces en los últimos años.
Ahora necesitamos incrementar la resolución
unas mil veces más
para obtener una mirada más profunda.
¿Cómo lo logramos?
Existen muchas técnicas para hacerlo.
Una es abrir el cráneo e introducir electrodos.
No me ofrezco para esa.
Muchos están proponiendo nuevas técnicas
de proyección por imágenes, incluso yo.
Contando con el resultado reciente de la IRM,
primero debemos preguntarnos lo siguiente,
¿esta tecnología será el final del camino?
La sabiduría convencional dice que la única forma
de obtener mayor resolución es con imanes más grandes,
pero a este punto, imanes más granes
solo ofrecen pequeñas mejoras en la resolución,
no aumentos por miles como necesitamos.
Propongo esta idea:
en vez de imanes más grandes,
hagamos mejores imanes.
Existen nuevos avances tecnológicos
en nanociencia
que al aplicarse a las estructuras magnéticas
han creado una nueva clase de imanes,
mediante los cuales podemos crear
patrones de campos magnéticos muy detallados
por todo el cerebro,
y, con ellos, podemos crear
figuras de interferencia similares a hologramas,
para tomar control preciso de muchos patrones,
tal como se muestra aquí al cambiar las cosas.
Podemos crear estructuras mucho más complejas
con arreglos ligeramente diferentes,
como haciendo un espirógrafo.
¿Y por qué esto nos importa?
En los últimos años, una gran cantidad
de esfuerzo en las IRM fueron para hacer
imanes realmente grandes, ¿cierto?
Sin embargo, la mayoría de los avances recientes
en resoluciónprovinieron
de soluciones ingeniosas y brillantes en codificación y decodificación,
en los transmisores y receptores de frecuencia de radio FM
en los sistemas de IRM.
A su vez, en vez de un campo magnético uniforme, utilicemos
patrones magnéticos estructurados
sumados a las frecuencias de radio FM.
Así, al combinar los patrones magnéticos
con los patrones del procesamiento de frecuencias de radio FM,
podemos incrementar de forma masiva
la información que se puede extraer
en un solo escaneo.
Además, podemos luego dividir en capas
nuestro conocimiento creciente sobre la estructura del cerebro y la memoria
para crear el incremento en los miles que necesitamos.
Al utilizar la IRMf deberíamos ser capaces de medir
no solo el fluido de sangre oxigenada,
sino el de las hormonas y neutrotransmisores que he mencionado
y quizás incluso la actividad neural directa.
Este es el sueño.
Seremos capaces de volcar nuestras ideas
en forma directa a los medios digitales.
¿Se imaginan si pudiésemos pasar por encima del lenguaje
y comunicarnos directamente mediante el pensamiento?
¿De qué seríamos capaces?
¿Y cómo aprenderemos a lidiar con
las verdades del pensamiento humano sin filtro?
Ustedes pensaban que la Internet es algo grande.
Estas son grandes preguntas.
Sería irresistible utilizarla como herramienta
para amplificar nuestras habilidades de pensamiento y comunicación.
Ciertamente, esta misma herramienta
podría llevar a la cura
del Alzheimer y enfermedades similares.
Tenemos pocas opciones más que abrir esta puerta.
De todas formas, elijan un año,
¿sucederá en 5 o 15 años?
Es difícil imaginar que tardará mucho más.
Tenemos que aprender cómo dar este paso juntos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)